yeah the finger gun in the thumbnails I
want to get this one to monetize if you
have a fake gun and a thumbnail that's
clearly not a real gun but looks like a
real gun but everyone knows it's not a
real gun so it's clearly a fake gun
they'll get you de monetize its 20/20 my
friends we're all trying to survive you
gotta be careful
[Music]
the rhythm section is not a movie about
music it's about assassins and
terrorists so the rhythm section is
directed by Reed Morano it stars Blake
Lively and Jude Law but mainly Blake
Lively her family was killed in a plane
crash which was actually a terrorist
attack you find this out well after it
happened so it's just talked about point
is at this phase in her life after her
family is gone she's in a very dark and
hopeless place in life this guy's like
hey that was a terrorist attack I can
help you get the guy who did it and Jude
Law goes fulled Liam Neeson from Batman
Begins it's like training there's
nothing well is everything doesn't say
that I'm just giving you the cliff notes
here the point is Jude Law trains her to
be an assassin so she can take out the
terrorist cell who killed her parents
which sounds ridiculous and also cliches
I'm saying it because movies that are
like we got to take out the terrorists
they're a dime a dozen and movies that
are like I got to avenge my dead family
also a dime a dozen but this movie
actually does bring some interesting
stuff to the table yes this normal
average everyday person who's gonna
train to take out the terrorists who
killed her family what I liked about
that is it never illustrates that she's
good at it and how good would you be at
that how good would I be at it not very
good I'd like to think I'd be good at it
I like to think I'd be the biggest
badass ever in reality I'd probably just
suck at the job because that's what
happens when you take normal people and
make them assassins or at least train
them to go on a revenge spree I wouldn't
really call her an assassin and this
movie does illustrate that which
bringing that up now is a way for me to
bring up the fact that the answer to a
few questions in this movie you might
have is well just cuz I mean Jude Law
and the movie monologues at nauseam
about how she's not gonna be good at
this she is not built for this even if
she does do it she's probably not gonna
live through it but you know what I'll
train you as an assassin anyway why just
cuz there are some conveniences that's
for sure also she needs to learn to go
for the eyes man Jude Law even tells her
in the movie if they have eyes go for
those they have balls go for those in a
few times she's being choked and I'm
like dig into that eye and pluck the
[ __ ] out or don't I mean you could
reach it I see that you could reach it
I'm just waiting for that Deadwood
moment you know he's just dangling
nothing never happened let's put that
the action scenes were really good
there's this one fight that Jude Law and
Blake Lively get into because the
training never quits when you're at the
cabin but he's just pissing her off
taunting her you know he's playing with
her but he wants her to rage out and
come at it and at a point I was like in
this whole fight sequence I'm pretty is
this
one shot has Wow how many movies out
there's like you know shaky-cam or it's
like hit alright cut hit another cut arm
hold cut just makes it look sloppy and
clearly they're trying to hide the fact
that the actors don't really know how to
fight the longer you can stay on the
shot the cleaner the fight is the more
you can see what's going on and there
was a car chase sequence I thought that
was really good to put you in the
passenger seat you feel like you're in
the car but I do got to say sometimes
the pacing of the movie was a bit slow
by the end I was like all right that
movie was 2 hours in less than 2 hours
ok I mean I wasn't ever bored to the
point of disliking the movie but the
movie undeniably feels longer than it
actually is because of some of the pace
which is why now we need to clarify when
I said the action sequences were good I
mean the couple that are actually in the
movie which makes you appreciate them
when they happen and they're actually
well done when they do happen but this
movie does not treat itself like in
action movies I don't go in here
thinking it is also the movie it's like
it wanted to address something which I
really like that they were addressing
and then at a point they were like that
forget that we're not addressing that
anymore we're not gonna hammer that
point home and just enjoy who's the
concept of when you take a normal
average everyday person and train them
to kill people and send them out there
to do it it's kind of really mess with
their head they got to get their hands
dirty if they're gonna roll in that
world and it looks like it's really
affecting her until at a point it just
kind of looks like it's not anymore I
will say the movie doesn't do the best
job at helping you keep track of
everything cuz there's a lot that
happens or a lot of names you need to
learn their names that you just like
what is that that person or is that god
it's a tangled web of people who know
people all that said in the end I
actually enjoyed this one the movies
well directed it's competently made
everyone in the movie did a good job the
movie has some pacing shortcomings but
most importantly for me I was invested
with Blake Lively's character's quest
and if you can get me invested in that I
can put up with some pacing shortcomings
in the end I walked out of the movie
having a good time no alcoholic for the
rest of the rhythm section have you seen
it what did you think about it or are
you going to see it are you looking
forward to it what's one of your
favorite revenge tales out there
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]